but what I want to do in this video is
talk about what a bitcoin is in more
general terms and what differentiating
characteristics they have compared to
other approaches surfer starters bitcoin
is just an electronic payment system and
by electronic payment system I mean it's
just a vehicle a conduit by which two
parties can transact over the Internet
I call these parties Alice and Bob and
let's say Alice for whatever reason
wants to give money to Bob over the
Internet and this may be because she
owes Bob money or maybe Bob is a
merchant and Alice's buying something
from Bob or maybe Bob is a
not-for-profit and Alice is making a
donation to Bob so there could be many
reasons why Alice is trying to pay Bob
over the Internet in some capacity
now if Bob is willing to accept bitcoins
which are a form of electronic payments
and Alice can go ahead and and send Bob
some value in bitcoins and really a
Bitcoin transaction between Alice and
Bob amounts to especially constructed a
sequence of numbers that Alice will
basically send over to Bob and this will
be done entirely over the internet these
numbers will have certain mathematical
properties that make it hard for someone
to really defraud the system or to
conduct some type of nefarious action on
the system and the way that alice is
actually going to conduct this
transaction in practice is either by
installing a special piece of software
which we call a Bitcoin client or she
can work with a third party service that
can handle these mechanics for her but
in either case either the client or the
service is going to generate these
numbers for Alice and on the flipside
Bob will also typically either have a
piece of software installed or he'll use
a third party service that will take
these numbers and allow him to do
something else with those numbers for
example Bob can in turn buy something of
his own with those numbers or you can
trade those numbers in for for real
money and so on and so forth all right
now one of the first questions you might
have and I kind of eluded this earlier
is is why would Bob even want to accept
bitcoins in the first place after all a
Bitcoin is just a bunch of numbers you
know what intrinsic value would it
conceivably have and it turns out quite
surprisingly that
bitcoins actually have real-world value
there are more and more merchants
popping up each day who accept bitcoins
for transactions there are also Bitcoin
exchanges places where you can go and
exchange bitcoins for more mainstream
currencies and some of these exchanges
include the major one is one called
mount GOx and at mount cox you can
exchange a Bitcoin for a euro a yen $1
and so on and so forth
now the current price of a Bitcoin the
current value of a Bitcoin in US dollars
as of this video is approximately 100 US
dollars per Bitcoin that number is
fluctuating this is the new currency and
there's going to be some fluctuation but
as people understand the currency better
the hope is that that fluctuation will
decrease but I think ultimately the
thing to keep in mind is that the value
of a Bitcoin is going to be derived from
the faith that you have in the value of
what you can procure with that Bitcoin
it's just like you would for a dollar or
euro or yen the faith that you have in
that currencies value is how you value
that currency now another question you
might have is why do people even bother
with bitcoins in the first place I mean
aren't there other more standard ways
why couldn't Alice and Bob use PayPal
like when they use a credit card number
to transact why couldn't Alice just send
Bob and electronic check you know what
why not use one of these other
approaches that are more well understood
that are more mainstream that are more
established why on earth would you
possibly want to mess with a good thing
so it turns out that there are a few
properties of bitcoins that are worth
noting and for starters there's privacy
it turns out that within the Bitcoin
ecosystem within the Bitcoin network
people can transact without divulging
who they are in the real world from the
perspective a Bitcoin Alice's identity
is going to be a sequence of numbers and
that sequence of numbers is effectively
going to function like a pseudonym for
Alice and that sequence of numbers has
nothing to do with two real world
identity nobody needs to know this is
Alice transacting all they need to worry
about is their pseudonym within the
system and this is kind of but not quite
like what you would get if you bought
something using cash you know that
capacity when you buy something using
cash then you don't have to provide any
details or proof reguar
who you are in the real world and that's
different from let's say using a credit
card where you have to provide your name
and your building address and so on or
let's say providing and electronic check
where you need to tie that electronic
check typically to your bank account
details okay now I do want to also
mention here that sometimes when you
have a cashed list or a transaction that
uses cash there is now the possibility
that people might try to use these
transactions for malicious purposes to
buy illicit goods and services that
definitely is a risk that occurs when
you provide anonymity and privacy but
there are certainly legitimate reasons
why somebody might want to conduct a
transaction privately and not have the
whole world know what their their
transacting another property of Bitcoin
is that it's open literally anyone can
get involved literally anyone who has an
internet connection can make a Bitcoin
transaction and all you need to do to
get started is I alluded to earlier is
download the special Bitcoin client and
the Bitcoin client or for that matter
you can use a service like Mount Cox
which will affect that we do the same
work as a client for you but the short
of it is that anyone who has a Bitcoin
client or was an account with with an
exchange like Mount Cox can engage in
Bitcoin transactions that transaction
that details of it the mechanics of it
will be transparent to the user
all these rest to worry about all Alice
needs to worry about is how much money
she has and whether she can give that
money to Bob the actual software
underneath will take care of all the
underlying mechanics of making that
transaction work now this is different I
mean when you think about a traditional
currency like I like a dollar if I want
to transact something online typically I
need a bank account I need a credit card
and so on and so forth then we often
take it for granted that there are
people out there who may not have access
to credit card you may not have a bank
account for example in the United States
alone it turns out I just look this up
the number of households without a bank
account I read it is somewhere north of
what eight percent so it's pretty high
there a lot of people out there who
wouldn't be able to conduct a
traditional internet transaction but if
you conduct a transaction using Bitcoin
and by the way there are people using
Bitcoin all over the world and literally
it doesn't matter where you are in the
world
as long as you have an internet
connection you can you can start
transacting bitcoins now another
property bitcoins that's worth
mentioning is that it's decentralized
there is no bank or or centralized
entity that can really control what's
happening in the in the Bitcoin
ecosystem it's all done in this kind of
ad hoc fashion and what that means is
that when you do a trans actor when
Alice transact with Bob over the
internet that transaction doesn't have
to go through a third party there's no
there's no bank that gets in the way of
that transaction and that can have
certain benefits as well for example
that means that no one entity can
directly control the money supply of
bitcoins and so on then that also means
that no one entity can let's say seizure
assets or for that matter no one entity
can reverse a transaction which is
definitely desirable for certain
merchants some merchants might not be
able to conduct business online because
of fraud concerns and if you have a
system where the transactions cannot be
charged back easily
then from the merchants perspective they
may be able to inhibit fraud of nearby
that might enable their business
entirely online now I want to point out
that this last property of
decentralization definitely causes
concern among some people around Bitcoin
after all when you think about it a
central authority like a bank does
perform an important function in the
context of a traditional currency for
example banks might validate currencies
they might validate transactions against
fraud now in Bitcoin this validation is
basically done in a decentralized way by
the other party the other nodes in the
Bitcoin network now the goal of the
remaining videos in this series is to
walk through the underlying mechanics of
Bitcoin transactions and really how
they're validated even though the system
is decentralized and there are some
pretty amazing techniques that are used
to make all this work so I suspect that
at this point you may have a ton of
questions about Bitcoin and that's
entirely to be expected Bitcoin is a
very complex protocol it has many moving
parts and I think it's critical when
you're trying to understand something as
complex and wrap your head around
something it is sophisticated as Bitcoin
it's important to get exposed to all the
part
first so that you can ultimately get a
flavor for how they fit together and
hopefully the other videos in this
series will help you to understand these
different parts and along the way
address many of the questions that you
might have